hi guys I don't know if you've noticed
but it's pretty hard to get a noticed on
YouTube nowadays so like myself there
are a lot of small youtubers but I'm
here today to tell you that being a
small youtuber doesn't have to mean all
that bad I mean you hear everywhere
about how hard it is to earn a living
from it to get the views and subscribers
that people deserve it's not all that
bad I just want to point out some
reasons why being a small youtuber in a
way it's a good thing might be hard to
believe but honestly it's not that bad
there are definitely good points to
being a small youtuber point number one
being nobody cares about you I'm not
starting off on a very good foot just
just hear me out here
hear me out nobody cares about you your
personal life what you might have done
in the past because we all do silly
things we all do ridiculous things that
we wish we'd never done before but
you're tiny so no one is going to bother
to dig up that dirt and make huge videos
about it and cause drama and hassle in
your life which is lovely it means that
you can just kind of slip under the rug
of all that YouTube drama and just focus
on what really matters making great
content we get to keep our personal
lives as personal as we wish them to be
and no one really cares not really and
that's a good thing not being a small
youtuber obviously you have a smaller
audience if you are like me and started
YouTube because you wanted to make a
positive influence on the world and
those who come across your videos of
course having a smaller audience base
might seem like a worse thing because it
means that you're not getting your
message across to as many people you're
not making a difference to as many
people as you possibly could be however
I feel like having a smaller audience
means that you have a more engaged
audience and let me explain this I'm not
trying to say that a bigger audience
doesn't love the person that they're
watching as much I just mean when it's a
smaller audience that gives you as a
youtuber more time to reply to comment
emails Facebook Instagram tumblr
snapchats
bloody everything when you have so many
people it's very hard to stay on top of
that so when you have less people it's
much easier to have that form of
engagement with your audience also I
love live streaming and I know quite a
few youtubers and content creators like
live streaming as well so if you have a
smaller audience this means that you can
actually have some pretty awesome live
conversations I don't know if you've
ever been to any of the larger youtubers
live streams but it is chaos you can't
even talk amongst yourselves in the
comment section because it's a
nonsensical it's pretty hilarious I will
give it that it doesn't allow the
youtuber to engage with what's really
being said with them and it doesn't
really allow the community to talk to
each other either however on the
flipside obviously they are getting more
views so there's the engagement in that
sense however there's not the kind of
conversational community engagement as
much try my hardest not to make anyone
feel that they're worse off I'm just
trying to tell you what's good for being
a small youtuber also with a smaller
audience come less trolls less roses
always a good thing that means less
awful comments and more constructive
criticism which is needed it's hard to
kind of sift through who is just saying
things to try and get a reaction out of
you and who is saying things because
they genuinely want you and your channel
to grow and then become better and as a
small youtuber you will get a lot more
constructive criticism over the trolls a
small youtuber you probably don't earn
enough to make a living off of YouTube
seems like an obvious downside however
it means that you're not relying on your
YouTube channel in a financial sense you
don't need it in that way to bring in an
income to help you live it's actually
just there because you love it because
you're passionate about it and I'm not
saying that the people who do it for a
living aren't passionate about it you
really have to be passionate because
you don't just start YouTube and start
making your living off it you know you
have to raft and work hard to get there
any person who does YouTube they would
only wish to be doing this for their job
however we don't have to rely on that it
takes away a lot of the pressure of
having to think about what's gonna give
us the most clicks and just focus on
doing what we want to do and what makes
us happy late let's bail I can't evil it
okay but let's back it up overall not
having to worry about the money aspect
of it and having a smaller audience this
means that there overall is less
pressure you can do what you want you
can go to university you can work if
you've got other ambitions you can
experiment with new videos if you want
to if you realize that perhaps the
content you're creating isn't what you
want to be doing in the future there's
not as much pressure and I think we
forget that with our huge ambitions we
see people like PewDiePie like so well
err like markiplier and they get to live
off YouTube they get to make videos
every day and that seems like the dream
I'm not trying to say it's not the dream
however I can't imagine the kind of
pressure that they're put under how they
get noticed in the street they've got a
lot of stuff to deal with that the
average person just doesn't have to
worry about and also it's stuff that no
one teaches you how to deal with either
so I really think what they do is
amazing I can't imagine what they go
through the bad and the good at the end
of the day we all have big aspirations
it would be amazing
to become the next big youtuber that
being a small youtuber is pretty cool as
well and I think we should just enjoy it
don't be disheartened by the fact that
you might not be as big as PewDiePie
markiplier or zoella you can't be them
you can only be you and the best version
of yourself so yeah you might not have
that YouTube fame you might not have all
those dollars rolling in but you
do have a small audience you have a
one-on-one engagement and if you like me
are doing this because you want to make
a positive difference in the world
you're able to do that too
so please don't let it this heart in you
what you do matters and I'm just getting
all cheesy and weird now so I'm probably
gonna stop hooray for us small youtubers
we we we got this who knows one day you
could become the next big thing but for
now just enjoy being small and the perks
that come along with it
have a lovely day or evening I really
hope that I've put this message across
across a trio of really hope I put this
message across as best as I can because
the stigma of relationships needing a
relationship the way that you're seen if
you're not in a relationship it's not
fair and I just want it